>> Larry: YOU'RE SURGING
IN THE POLLS RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS GREAT YOU ARE ON THE
COVER OF TIME MAGAZINE.
>> WHO WOULD HAVE KNOWN.
>> Larry: YOU WERE ON CBS
MORNING SHOW.
YOU ARE ON FIRE, BERNIE.
THIS IS LIKE THE YEAR PEOPLE ARE
ANTICIPATING FIRSTS.
>> FIRST WOMAN PRESIDENT, WE
ALREADY HAVE THE FIRST BLACK
PRESIDENT, BILL CLINTON.
WE JUST HAD THE FIRST MUSLIM
PRESIDENT.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SEE
THAT.
>> AND THE GUY WASN'T EVEN BORN
IN AMERICA, HOW'S THAT?
>> Larry: FIRST KENYAN AND
MUSLIM PRESIDENT.
DO YOU THINK AMERICA IS READY
FOR THE FIRST SOCIALIST
PRESIDENT?.
>> YES, I DO, I DO. I THINK WE
UNDERSTAND THE, WHAT DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISM MEANS.
>> Larry: WHAT IS DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISM.
>> IT IS LEARNING FROM COUNTRIES
LIKE DENMARK, SWEDEN, NORWAY,
WHO HAVE FREE HEALTHCARE FOR ALL
OF THEIR PEOPLE, FREE COLLEGE
EDUCATION FOR ALL OF THEIR
PEOPLE.
>> Larry: IS THAT THEIR WAY OF
KEEPING THEM IN FINLAND?  KEEP
IT 100.
DO YOU THINK PEOPLE ARE AFRAID
OF THE WORD SOCIALISM.
>> THEY HEAR SOCIALISM, OH,
SOCIALISM OF WHAT.
ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE MY DELVED
EGG DEVILED EGG?
>> NO WHAT IT IS ..
>> BY THE WAY, SOCIALISM TAKES
FANTASTIC.
>> YOU LIKE THIS.
>>
>> Larry: YOU ARE A VERY
INTERESTING CANDIDATE BECAUSE
YOU ARE REALLY ONE OF A KIND.
WE NEVER HAD A JEWISH PRESIDENT,
THAT WE KNOW OF, RIGHT?  YOU
KNOW WHAT I AM SAYING.
YOU MAY BE THE OLDEST PERSON
EVER TO BECOME PRESIDENT.
YOU ARE 74?
>> YES.
IF YOU BECAME PRESIDENT GOD
FORBID SOMETHING DOES, I AM A
TRYING TO KEEP IT 100 WOULD YOU
BE COMFORTABLE WITH A WEEKEND AT
BERNIE SITUATION?  WHERE, TO GET
YOU THROUGH THE REST OF THE
ADMINISTRATION?
>> I THINK THE GOOD NEWS IS, I
HAVE BEEN BLESSED WITH GOOD
HEALTH.
>> Larry: IF YOU COULD JUST DO
THIS, JUST IN CASE, COULD YOU
JUST PUT THESE SUNGLASSES ON?
JUST IN CASE WE HAVE TO DO THE
WEEKEND AT BERNIE THING.
>> THAT IS AWESOME.
HOW IS THAT?  THAT IS FANTASTIC.
OH, THAT IS AWESOME.
YES.
>> YOU CAN KEEP THOSE.
>> YOU KNOW, THIS WAS HORRIBLE,
BERNIE, YOU WERE MAKING A SPEECH
AND SOME PEOPLE FROM BLACK LIVES
MATTER JUST INTERRUPTED YOU.
>> UH-HUH.
>> Larry: I WILL BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
I HATE IT WHEN BLACK PEOPLE
INTERRUPT ME.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD BE A
GOOD WAY TO GET BLACK PEOPLE TO
FEEL THE BERN?
>> I WILL SAY THAT THE ISSUES --
>> Larry: IT IS SO HORRIBLE
THAT THING COULD HAPPEN ANYWAY,
INTERRUPTING PEOPLE IS JUST THE
RUDEST THING, BUT ANYWAY, GO
AHEAD.
I AM SORRY.
>> YOU INTERRUPTED ME AGAIN.
I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO DO IT.
>> Larry: THAT IS VERY RUDE.
>> Larry: YOU MAY HAVE TO DO
THINGS YOU ARE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH.
I AM SORRY.
>> WE'RE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING
>> WE CAN TO END INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM IN THIS COUNTRY AND MORE.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH REAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
>> Larry: YOU COULD SAY MY
PLANS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM AND HELPING THE BLACK
COMMUNITY ARE UNFLEEK.
>> UNFLEEK? OKAY.
>> Larry: UNFLEEK.
MY PLANS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM ARE UNFLEEK.
>> LARRY WILMORE SAYS I SHOULD
TELL YOU THAT MY PLAN FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM IS
UNFLEEK. THAT IS IT.
I'M ON MY WAY NOW.
>> Larry: OKAY.
SO, THE GUY WHO IS MAKING ALL
THE NOISE RIGHT NOW IS DONALD
TRUMP.
I DON'T KNOW WHY DONALD TRUMP IS
WINNING RIGHT NOW BUT I DO HAVE
ONE THEORY IF YOU TAKE
EVERYTHING ELSE AWAY YOU KNOW
WHAT HE HAS NOBODY ELSE HAS?
>> 5 BILLION BUCKS
>> NO, A HAT. HAVE YOU SEEN THE
HAT?  MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
CORNIEST HAT I HAVE EVER SEEN,
BUT BERNIE I THINK IF YOU GET A
HAT I THINK THAT'S THE WAY TO
GET PEOPLE TO HEAR YOUR MESSAGE.
>> I AM OPEN TO --
>> Larry: HERE IS THE THING.
A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN AMERICA
RIGHT NOW, A LOT OF THINGS
PEOPLE CAN'T AGREE ON. WE'RE IN
A SOUL FOOD RESTAURANT
I THINK WE CAN AGREE ON ONE
THING.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> Larry: BLACK-EYED PEAS
MATTER.
ALL RIGHT?
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> Larry: HERE YOU GO, BERNIE.
>> AND YOU THINK THIS WILL TAKE
ME OVER THE TOP?
>> Larry: THAT WILL BRING
AMERICA TOGETHER.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR I AM NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE BLACK EYED
PEAS BECAUSE THEY DON'T REALLY
MATTER ANYMORE, I AM TALKING
ABOUT ACTUAL BLACK EYED PEAS.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR.
THANKS A LOT, BERNIE.
>> THANK YOU, LARRY.
>> Larry: FEEL THE BERN,
EVERYBODY, FEEL THE BERN.